- This right here is an
equation for a parabola
and the role of this video
is to find an alternate
or to explore an alternate method
for finding the focus and directrix
of this parabola from the equation.
So the first thing I like to
do is solve explicitly for y.
I don't know, my brain just processes
things better that way.
So, let's get this 23 over
four to the right hand side.
So let's add 23 over four to both sides
and then we'll get y is
equal to negative one-third
times x minus one squared
plus 23 over four.
Now let's remind ourselves
what we've learned
about foci and directrixes,
I think is how to say it.
So, the focus.
If the focus of a parabola
is at the point a, b
and the directrix,
the directrix, directrix
is the line y equals k.
We've shown in other videos
with a little bit of hairy algebra
that the equation of the parabola
in a form like this is going to be
y is equal to one over
two times b minus k.
This b minus k is then the difference
between this y coordinate
and this y value,
I guess you could say.
Times x minus one squared
plus b plus k.
I'm sorry, not x minus one.
I'm getting confused with this.
x minus a squared.
x minus a squred plus b plus k
over two.
The focus is a,b
and the directrix is y equals k
and this is gonna be the
equation of the parabola.
Well, we've already seen the technique
where, look, we can see
the different parts.
We can see that, okay,
this x minus one squared.
Actually, let me do this
in a different color.
This x minus one squared
corresponds to the x minus a squared
and so one
corresponds to a,
so just like that, we know that a is going
to be equal to one
and actually let me just write that down.
a is equal to one in this
example right over here.
And then you could see
that the negative one-third
over here corresponds to
the one over two b minus k
and you would see that the 23 over four
corresponds to the b plus k over two.
Now the first technique that we explored,
we said, "Okay, let's
set negative one-third
"to this thing right over here.
"Solve for b minus k."
We're not solving for b or k,
we're solving for the
expression b minus k.
So you got b minus k equals something.
And then you could use
23 over four and this
to solve for b plus k.
So you get b plus k equals something
and then you have two
equations, two unknowns,
you can solve for b and k.
What I wanna do in this video
is explore a different method
that really uses our
knowledge of the vertex
of a parabola to be able to figure out
where the focus and the
directrix is going to be.
So let's think about the vertex
of this parabola right over here.
Remember, the vertex, if the
parabola is upward opening
like this, the vertex
is this minimum point.
If it is downward opening,
it's going to be this maximum point.
And so when you look over here,
you see that you have a negative one-third
in front of the x minus one squared.
So this quantity over here is either going
to be zero or negative.
It's not going to add to 23 over four,
it's either gonna add
nothing or take away from it.
So this thing's going
to hit a maximum point,
when this thing is zero,
and that's just gonna go down from there
and when this thing is zero,
y is going to be equal to 23 over four.
So our vertex is going
to be that maximum point.
Well, when does this equal zero?
Well, when x equals one.
When x equals one, you
get one minus one squared.
So zero squared times negative one-third,
this is zero.
So when x is equal to one,
we're at our maximum y
value of 23 over four
which five and three-fourths.
Actually, let me write that as a .
Actually, I'll leave
just that's our vertex.
23 over four
and it is a downward opening parabola.
So actually, let me start to draw this.
So we'd get some axis here.
So we have to go all the way
up to five and three-fourths.
So.
Let's make this our y, this is our y axis.
This is the x axis.
That's the x axis.
We're gonna see, we're gonna go to one.
Let's call that one. Let's call that two.
And then I wanna get, let's see,
if I go to five and three-fourths,
let's go up to, let's see
one, two, three, four
five, six, seven.
We can label 'em.
One, two, three, four
five, six and seven
and so our vertex is right over here.
One comma 23 over four,
so that's five and three-fourths.
So it's gonna be right around
right around there
and as we said, since
we have a negative value
in front of this x minus one squared term,
I guess we could call it,
this is going to be a
downward opening parabola.
This is going to be a maximum point.
So our actual parabola is going to look
is going to look something
it's gonna look something like this.
It's gonna look something like this
and we could, obviously,
I'm hand drawing it,
so it's not going to be exactly perfect,
but hopefully you get the general idea
of what the parabola is going
look like and actually,
let me just do part of it,
'cause I actually don't
know that much information
about the parabola just yet.
I'm just gonna draw it like that.
So we don't know just yet
where the directrix and focus is,
but we do know a few things.
The focus is going to sit on the same,
I guess you could say, the
same x value as the vertex.
So if we draw, this is x equals one,
if x equals one, we
know from our experience
with focuses, foci, (laughs) I guess,
that they're going to
sit on the same axis as
the vertex.
So the focus might be
right over here and then the directrix
is going to be equidistant
on the other side,
equidistant on the other side.
So the directrix might
be something like this.
Might be right over here.
And once again, I haven't
figured it out yet,
but what we know is
that because this point,
the vertex, sits on the parabola,
by definition has to be equidistant
from the focus and the directrix.
So.
This distance has to be the same
as this distance right over here
and what's another way of thinking
about this entire distance?
Remember, this coordinate right over here
is a, b and this is the line
y is equal to k.
This is y equals k.
So what's this distance in yellow?
What's this difference in y going to be?
Well, you could call that, in this case,
the directrix is above the focus,
so you could say that this would be k
minus b
or you could say it's the absolute value
of b minus k.
This would actually always work.
It'll always give you kind
of the positive distance.
So if we knew what the
absolute value of b minus k is,
if we knew this distance,
then just split it
in half with the directrix is gonna be
that distance, half the distance above
and then the focus is gonna
be half the distance below.
So let's see if we can figure this out.
And we can figure this out because we see
in this, I guess you
could say, this equation,
you can see where b minus k is involved.
One over two times b minus k needs to be
equal to negative one-third.
So let's solve for b minus k.
So we get
we get one over two times b minus k
is going to be equal
to negative one-third.
Once again, this corresponds to that.
It's going to be equal
to negative one-third.
We could take the reciprocal of both sides
and we get two times b minus k
is equal to, is equal to
three, is equal to three.
Now we can divide both sides
we can divide both sides by two
and so we're gonna get
we're gonna get b
b minus k is equal to
is equal to, what is that,
three-halves, three-halves.
b minus k is equal to, oh,
let me make sure that has
to be a negative three,
so this has to be negative three-halves.
And so if you took the
absolute value of b minus k
you're gonna get positive three-halves,
or if you took k minus b,
you're going to get positive three-halves.
So just like that, using this part,
just actually matching
the negative one-third
to this part of this equation,
we're able to solve for the absolute value
of b minus k which is
going to be the distance
between the y axis in the y direction
between the focus and the directrix.
So this distance right over here
is three-halves.
So what is half that distance?
And the reason why I care
about half that distance
is because then I can calculate
where the focus is, because
it's going to be half
that distance below the vertex
and I could say, whatever that distance is
is going to be that distance also
above the directrix.
So half that distance,
so one half times three-halves
is equal to three-fourths.
So just like that,
we're able to figure out
the directrix is going to
be three-fourths above this.
So I could say the
directrix, so let me see,
I'm running out of space,
the directrix is gonna be y is equal
to the y coordinate of the focus.
Sorry, the y coordinate of the vertex.
I might be careful with my language.
It's gonna be equal to the
y coordinate of the vertex
plus three-fourths, plus three- fourths.
So plus three-fourths, which
is equal to 26 over four,
which is equal to, what is that,
that's equal to six and a half.
So this right over here,
actually I got pretty close when I drew it
is actually going to be the directrix.
Y is equal to six and a half
and the focus, well, we
know the x coordinate
of the focus, a is
going to be equal to one
and b is going to be three-fourths less
than the y coordinate of the directrix.
So 23 over four minus three-fourths.
Gonna be 23 over four
23 over four minus three-fourths
which is 20 over four,
which is just equal to
which is just equal to five.
And we are done.
That's the focus, one comma five.
Directrix is y is equal to six and a half.